Yeah,
alright.
Right.
Live.
What's up man?
How are you?
Hey,
I'm pretty good.
I'm excited.
I walked in on a pool game that was a
barely squeaked it out.
It was a very nice shot to,
to end it though.
That's the way to end it.
So,
uh,
I've been reading your book man tribe.
I really enjoy it.
It's really good and it's,
it's so,
uh,
it resonates.
It's very interesting.
I will into the first chapter.
I wanted to move in with the native
Americans.
It was such a,
I mean it was one of the more
interesting aspects of it was uh,
something that I didn't know about,
which was the European settlers that had
been kidnapped and were living with the
native Americans and then when they were
rescued,
many of them wanted to go back.
Yeah.
Or they would go into hiding so they
wouldn't have to be repatriated to
colonial society.
They wanted to stay with their adopted
tribes.
And then there was also a lot of,
um,
a lot of young white people,
particularly white men and young women
too,
who basically absconded across the
frontier into tribal society.
A,
they fled white society,
they didn't like it,
and,
and as Benjamin Franklin pointed out,
we have lots of call colonial colonial's
fleeing to the Indians and we have not
one example of an Indian as they were
called fleeing to white society.
Yeah,
that was one of the more fascinating
aspects of it.
I didn't anticipate that.
I thought that there would be a lot of
native Americans,
so it'd be like,
wow,
this is a way better look at all the
food looking at the houses.
And
I mean they had plenty of food,
you know,
whatever their success,
success,
very successful society.
In fact they were,
they had better nutrition than the
whites did a more varied diet,
um,
and a much,
much more egalitarian society than
colonial society.
That was also interesting about it.
Um,
when you were talking about the women
that had moved in with the native
Americans and we're expressing how much
more freedom they experienced.
Yeah.
I mean,
Indian Society,
native society wasn't crushed by a
Christian morality.
So you could divorce,
you could marry as a woman,
you can marry whom you wanted.
You could get divorced.
You can do whatever you wanted.
It was very,
very galatarian.
What they've shown is that,
um,
the in societies where everyone is
necessary for food production,
food production,
uh,
everyone more or less equal.
And in an agrarian societies,
agricultural societies,
industrial societies,
you have large segments of the
population.
Often women who are not involved in food
production,
they are involved in reproduction.
And so they're,
um,
equality goes
down.
Wow.
It's just,
it's almost like society as we've
created over the last couple of hundred
years is almost totally incompatible
with,
with human genetics or with the human
body or the human spirit or whatever.
Well,
if you look at,
I mean,
genetics is complicated.
obviously on some level,
industrial,
modern society is very successful.
We have 7 billion of us.
Um,
uh,
but as wealth goes up in a society,
as modernity goes up in a society,
the suicide rate goes up,
the depression rate goes up,
schizophrenia goes up in urban
environments.
Um,
they're not good for the human psyche.
We are designed.
We evolve the lave in groups of 30,
40 people in a harsh environment,
totally reliant on one another.
For survival,
a,
that creates a huge amount of equality
within a group and loyalty within a
group.
That's what we are designed for.
Genetically.
A modern society allows the individual
to be independent from the group,
which is in some ways a great
liberation,
uh,
and other ways it can lead to a profound
alienation and depression.
Yeah,
it's,
it's just a confusing thing.
It seems for people to be amongst so
many people,
but to be alone.
Yeah.
I mean,
we're not wired to be confronted with
strangers all day long and I live in New
York City and I love New York City,
but all day long you,
you encounter strangers and you don't
and you don't recognize anybody so you
can be alone in a crowd,
which is not something that human beings
have experienced until quite recently in
their history.
Yeah.
Um,
that was,
I think one of the more disturbing parts
about this idea that these people were
kidnapped by the native Americans and
wanted to stay with them was that
whatever that native American life was
like,
however they were living,
that just seemed to just resonate with
them.
It seemed to,
it seemed to be what was right.
Well,
we're,
we're wired to want to feel like we
belong to a group.
A native American society was a sexually
quite relaxed.
I was quite a Galitary Ian.
I'm in a hunter gatherer society.
You really can't accumulate wealth very
well because these societies are often
nomadic,
so you can only accumulate as much
wealth as you can carry,
which isn't much.
Um,
and,
and ultimately in societies like that,
as in a platoon in combat,
which is another part of my book,
obviously,
um,
you're,
you're primarily valued,
valued for your contribution to the
group.
And that has been lost in modern
society.
People are enormously selfserving.
Capitalism basically instructs us to do
so.
Uh,
that's a whole other evolutionary
imperative,
which is also important,
but in our society is way out of whack.
So we are wired to serve ourselves and
we are wired to serve the group and in a
healthy society,
those two,
those two are in a dynamic tension with
each other.
And in ballots,
in modern society,
there really is no group to serve.
Uh,
and it leads to a really profound sense
of meaninglessness for a lot of people.
Cool.
Yeah.
Uh,
I also found it pretty fascinating that
when you were really young you,
when you,
when you were working,
I think you said you were working
construction,
so it was a,
I'm trying to remember the story you
were about to,
can you were just saying that you were
talking to someone that you're working
with and they were telling you to slow
down because some of us,
some of us have to do this for.
That's about it.
Yeah.
I forgot about that story.
I was on a construction crew and it was
a highway department of my town and you
know,
a lot of these guys are kind of lifers
in our department.
Not a particularly challenging job,
um,
in a,
in a sense,
uh,
but you were on your feet all day long
in the sun or whatever.
And,
and so,
uh,
you know,
I was a young guy and I,
I wanted to sort of prove my mettle or
whatever I was.
I was,
we were digging a trench and I was
digging like crazy and a and an older
guy came up to me,
you know,
he's probably in his sixties and he came
up to me and clapped me on the shoulder.
He said,
son,
you want to slow down there,
you know,
why some of us are going to have to do
this job our whole lives.
And he knew I was a college kid.
He knew I wasn't going to.
Um,
and I said,
just slow down,
you know,
no one needs to work this past.
It's just a,
it was a really interesting that you
were longing for something you were
saying like almost to go wrong.
So everybody had a band together,
whether it was a hurricane or something
and that,
that mundane life of just work and doing
things you don't really want to do.
Well,
I mean,
the irony about modern society is that
is removed hardship and danger from
everyday life and it's in the face of
hardship and danger that people come to
understand their value to their society
and there's a,
they get their sense of meaning from
that.
And so what you have is when,
uh,
you know,
during the blitz in London,
for example,
30,000
people were killed by German bombs.
It was a horror show over the course of
six months.
It was ghastly,
but people are sleeping shoulder to
shoulder in the tube stations and
putting out fires with bucket brigades
and digging people out of rubble.
And they were acting as a unified
society.
And the English government was prepared
for mass psychiatric casualties because
as a civilian population getting bombed
at bets and the opposite happened.
Admissions to psych wards went down
during the blitz and then back up after
the bombing stopped.
And,
um,
and then afterwards it was an enormous
nostalgia in England for the blitz.
For those days.
I'm as tragic as they were because
English society felt other people felt
like they were together.
Later I was,
I went back to Sarajevo where I'd been
during the siege of Sarajevo in the
early nineties.
And civilians would tell me,
you know,
this is 20 years later,
20 years after the war,
people say,
wow,
a lot of us miss the war because we were
better people back then.
We took care of each other.
I've talked about that with September
11th.
Um,
I went to New York City.
I'm about,
I guess it was maybe six months after
September 11th.
And uh,
I was there a couple times and the,
the before September 11th,
after September 11th,
there was a very clear difference in the
way people were behaving.
People seem to be more,
more friendly,
more open.
They were really appreciative of first
responders.
Um,
I was there once in a friend of mine.
She fainted.
And so they called the fire department,
came to check her out.
And,
and when the firemen showed up,
man,
you would think fucking superhero showed
up.
It was amazing.
Everybody was so happy to see him.
And it was in stark contrast to the way
people used to behave and treat each
other.
And it was directly because of having
experienced this horrific event.
Well,
adversity produces pro pro social
behaviors in people.
Adversity makes people act well.
Uh,
the lack of adversity,
safety and comfort allow people to act
selfishly.
Uh,
so after nine slash 11,
the suicide rate went down in New York.
Uh,
the violent crime rate went down in New
York.
Vietnam vets reported that their ptsd
symptoms went down after nine slash 11.
Um,
what happens is people suddenly feel
that they're needed by their society,
by their people,
and if you feel needed,
you are able to ignore your own personal
troubles is when someone in England and
an efficient and English official said
during the blitz in London,
he said,
it's amazing.
We have the chronic neurotics of
peacetime driving ambulances.
Um,
and if you think about in terms of
evolution,
if adversity in danger produced bad
human behaviors,
we wouldn't be here today.
Another way to say that is we are the
descendants of the individuals 100,000
years ago who acted well in a crisis.
The people that acted badly to crisis
and just took care of themselves and
didn't take care of their people,
their group,
those,
those people,
those groups died out.
It's people,
it's groups that encouraged a form of
altruism itself,
self sacrifice of individuals for the
group.
During a crisis.
Those groups survive.
That DNA gets passed onto us.
And did you gain a deeper appreciation
for this because of your time as a war
journalist?
Did it sort of manifests itself in your
mind because of that?
Well,
I,
I.
This book came to me and to sort of two
step process.
First of all,
when I was young man,
I had a surrogate uncle figure in my
life,
very important person to be named Ellis
Ellis settle.
He was a half Lakota Sioux half Apache
and he was born in Nineteen,
29 on a wagon out west.
It live an extraordinary life.
He was very,
very educated,
self educated,
and at one point he said to me,
you know,
it's so funny.
All throughout the history of this
country,
white people were always running off to
join the Indians and the Indians never
ran off to join the white people.
And I filed that away.
In my mind,
I kind of liked the idea of it.
I thought it was.
I hoped it was true.
I didn't know if it was true and then
decades later I was with American
soldiers on a remote outpost in
Afghanistan and uh,
called Restrepo and I made a documentary
film by that name with my colleague Tim
Hetherington,
and there was almost daily combat.
There was no,
no link to the outside world,
no Internet.
There was no electricity for awhile.
They just slept in the dirt.
They got shot at everyday.
We got shot at every day.
Uh,
there was no women out there.
There was nothing but combat and
Tarantulas and pallets of water and Mras
and Ammo.
That was it for a year.
Those boys are out there for over a year
and they very psyched to come back to
Italy where they're based at the end of
their deployment.
You can imagine that had some pretty
good parties planned.
But after that died down,
he real depression set in.
And by the time I got caught up with
them again in Vicenza and interviewed
them,
many of them said that they wanted to
go.
They didn't want to come back to
America.
They wanted to go back out to restrepo.
And it reminded me of what Ellis had
said and I thought,
what is it that's why is it that no one
wants to come home?
Like,
what is it?
And I realized it's not that they,
they want war,
that they're not sociopaths,
that,
uh,
you know,
like they don't,
they don't want to be out there killing
people and getting shot at.
They missed each other.
They missed the intense communalism of
life in a platoon on a,
on a remote hilltop in combat.
And um,
and that's an inch and instruct me.
I studied anthropology in college.
Oh my God.
A platoon in combat effectively
reproduces our human evolution,
right?
I mean,
we evolved to live in groups of that
size and in a harsh environment and
that's what a platoon is.
And so of course it resonated with them,
resonated genetically with them.
And,
um,
I gotta say it's tough.
It was,
as it was out there,
there was a weird,
also weird,
I don't quite want to call it a
euphoria,
but a strange sense of wellbeing out
there that I missed enormously when I
left as well.
You missed it.
Oh,
enormously.
Yes.
Did you try to rationalize it?
Did you try to,
when did you sit alone with it and try
to figure out what it was or did you
just accept it?
I mean,
I,
you know,
I've been covering wars since the early
nineties.
I started going to Afghanistan in the
mid nineties.
Um,
I came back from,
from Restrepo,
you know,
we were in a lot of combat.
I almost,
almost killed a couple of times,
so I had some sort of trauma issues.
I mean,
everybody did a,
my marriage started to fall apart.
That was not coincidental by the way.
I now realized that the timing was
significant.
Um,
it took me awhile to understand that and
I think and we're real depression and it
took me a while to understand that my
depression was partly connected to the
fact that I was no longer part of a
group and,
and a,
but took a long time for me to figure
that out while I was experiencing all
that.
I just felt like I was in some kind of,
that I was behind bulletproof
bulletproof plexiglass and I was on the
inside and everyone I cared about was on
the other side of the plexiglass and I
couldn't reach them that they were
somehow inaccessible to me.
I couldn't hear them,
I couldn't touch them.
I was alone in this plexiglass cage and
that's what it sort of felt like.
I was incredibly depressed.
And then Tim,
my good friend and brother and colleague
who I made Restrepo with,
he was killed in combat in Libya and
that was the final blow.
I mean,
I really crashed.
My marriage ended.
I mean,
I was a real mess for awhile.
How did you pull out of it?
Uh,
I,
you know,
I just,
I had a,
a year or so in the wilderness,
I think psychologically and um,
you know,
humans are evolved obviously to deal
with trauma.
I mean,
eventually,
if trauma was incapacitating to people
for years or lifetimes,
we wouldn't exist.
Right?
I mean,
our,
our history as a species involved a huge
amount of trauma.
So we are designed to react to trauma by
protecting ourselves emotionally and
physically for a certain amount of time
for some weeks or months,
maybe a year or two,
and then the slowly come out of it and
continue functioning.
That's exactly what happened to me.
What do you do?
Did you get something out of it?
I mean,
obviously it's a terrible experience to
be depressed for that long and to go
through all that.
But did you get some sort of an
understanding of yourself out of it?
Oh,
absolutely.
I mean,
I,
um,
some ways,
I mean,
I,
my,
my marriage ended,
um,
by,
you know,
moved out of my home,
uh,
was living in a very sort of a thread,
bare existence for awhile.
I sort of gave up everything that,
that made me feel safe and protected in
the world.
I mean,
financially,
no,
I just sort of happened,
you know,
financially,
emotionally.
Uh,
I wasn't doing,
I wasn't working as a reporter for a
while.
I'd stopped reporting after Tim got
killed and I just sort of hit the reset
button on myself as a person.
And,
and,
and I sort of,
um,
when I came back from that I,
I,
the things I added to my life were very
solid.
Uh,
we're,
we're very,
very good things.
And um,
I sort of started from zero again and
that really kind of worked.
And um,
and I also stopped.
I mean I didn't have a drinking problem
but I,
but I stopped drinking.
I stopped drinking alcohol and that the
drinking alcohol I made me,
it made me drink alcohol,
made me feel good,
right?
I mean,
I'm really happy drunk.
And when I was depressed for,
for a bunch of reasons,
if I drank,
I felt great.
And so there's a real incentive to do
that.
And I realized that it was depriving me
of experiencing my actual life.
Like my actual life was filled with some
very tough things at the moment.
And if you self medicate your way
through them,
you actually,
those things are taken from you.
It's your life,
your life you're going through.
And if they were taking it and I
realized I might lose the experience of
these things.
And,
you know,
my ex wife and I are like quick,
good friends now and ended up partly
because,
um,
I decided to try and experience the loss
of the marriage as directly as possible.
And that involved not drinking.
Did you,
during this time of depression,
did you consider or did you take any
antidepressants?
So,
no,
just likewise,
like I,
I,
I mean,
I was talking to someone professional
about how I felt because I was a little
worried about myself.
But,
um,
as I said to her,
I said,
you know,
if I was on antidepressants,
it might allow me to accept.
It might make me feel good enough to
accept a life that isn't really working
very well.
Yeah,
that's a,
as a person who's not depressed,
it's a very,
uh,
it's a slippery argument for me because
I,
I'm just an outside observer,
you know,
and when I talked to people that are
depressed and I always wonder like,
how,
how much of what you're doing is life
circumstances,
how much is it actual,
some sort of a mental imbalance,
some sort of a chemical imbalance that
you just are unfortunately born with.
I mean,
listen,
I'm not a shrink.
Obviously there are people that
encountered their first impression is
teenagers and struggle with a very
dangerous illness their whole lives.
Yeah.
I'm not talking about that kind of
depression,
depression.
I don't know why.
I mean,
isn't circumstance nurture genetics
involved in that?
For me,
I,
you know,
my depression was a very healthy
reaction to some tough circumstances I
was going through.
I was having a completely healthy self
protective reaction to what was going on
in my life.
And when you say you started putting
positive things in your life,
good solid things in your life,
like what kind of things?
A good relationship?
Um,
I started working again.
I started being physically really active
again,
uh,
I mean I just,
I started boxing actually and,
and uh,
and that was inspiring and stuff and
that was incredibly frightening to me.
It just,
you know,
that kind of is very,
very hard and among other things and uh,
but all that stuff really was really,
really good for me.
One of the things that I've been
dwelling on a lot lately is how
important struggle is.
And for me personally,
um,
I,
I do a lot of things and I do a lot of
things that I'm terrible at and uh,
I feel like the more happy I am is when
I just get slightly better at these
terrible things.
Like that's when I feel like little bits
of progress
that is exactly how we're wired to react
to success.
And if you sort of think about it,
think about us as a species,
as an animal.
If you're presented with a challenge and
you get a little dose of,
of endorphins and dopamine,
some feel good chemicals when you do a
task well that will encourage you to
keep doing that task and keep looking
for success,
small successes in your life,
which is exactly how people adapt and
survive in harsh circumstances.
Um,
the problem with affluent modern society
is it takes away all of the tasks of
survival,
right?
You,
not no one in this room I don't think is
having to figure out every morning how
to literally physically survive where,
where am I going to get my,
the berries,
I'm going to eat today,
we're going to go to kill something that
I can eat.
How am I going to avoid the enemy?
Like we're not thinking like that.
And which is enormous blessing,
right?
I mean,
it's an enormous luxury to live like
that.
The downside is you don't get this sense
of mastery over your circumstances.
You actually don't feel responsible for
your own survival.
You don't feel like you are earning your
own survival in the world.
You feel like it's being handed to you.
And I grew up in an affluent suburb and
I never had a sense as a young man that
I was contributing in any way to the
fact that I was physically alive on the
planet.
And well,
that's the,
that's,
that's very,
very recent in human history that young,
young men could afford to feel that way.
It's,
um,
again,
it's a blessing,
but also a bit of a curse.
It's the most disconnected amongst us
are always spoiled rich kids that handed
everything to them and don't have a,
an understanding at all about the
consequences of their behavior.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that kind of life is correlated with
depression.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I mean,
drug abuse.
Yeah,
all that,
all that stuff.
And the,
the um,
uh,
the suicide rate is rising fastest among
middle aged white men who,
if you listen to some people,
um,
are apparently arguably the demographic
that they're are most privileged in this
society.
Yes.
Doing the best with this civilization
that we've constructed during the wars
biologically in terms of how they
adapted it and psychologically.
Yeah.
The psychologically is a big part of the
biology.
Right.
And the thing about this quest for
stuff,
you know,
and one of the things I thought was
really interesting in the book where you
were outlining the key factors for
happiness and that wealth is not the
primary one,
but being good at something,
being recognized for being good at
something,
being a part of a group,
like all these things were primary.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you think about it,
and again,
in evolutionary terms,
um,
we are safest when we are needed.
Yeah.
So if you're in a group and the group
needs you,
your status in the group is secure.
And it had better be because humans do
not survive alone in the wild.
A alone human in nature is a dead human,
right?
We're primates.
We're social primates alone.
Primate in the,
in,
in nature is a dead primate.
And uh,
for most of the species.
And we get our,
we get our safety or protection from the
fact that we worked very,
very well in groups.
We don't have long claws.
We don't have a sharp teeth.
We can't run very fast.
We can't climb trees worth a damn.
Were extremely vulnerable.
And we get our safety and our dominance
in the natural world from our ability to
work in a group.
So if you're necessary to that group,
you're safe.
So people get very depressed when
circumstances in their life change and
they're suddenly not needed,
right when people get old and retire
there at very,
very high risk of depression.
And sometimes suicide,
uh,
when people lose their job and can't
find a job there at extremely high risk
of depression and suicide.
So when the economy takes a downturn as
it did in 2008,
um,
and the unemployment rate goes up,
the suicide rate immediately goes up.
It tracks the unemployment rate almost.
Exactly.
And one of the points I make in my book
is that a very small number of mostly
men collapsed the US economy in 2008 and
most of them living on was working on
Wall Street.
And there was a direct.
I read an article in an academic journal
on Epod,
a epidemics,
um,
that there was a directly attributable
to the financial collapse.
There were five or 6,000
additional suicides in the United
States,
mostly middle aged white men.
Okay.
And sort of professional prefer
professional people and um,
of,
of all of all classes.
And um,
and the,
uh,
and I realized that that was almost
exactly the casualty rate from the two
wars from Iraq and Afghanistan.
In other words,
something that happened at home
economically killed just as many
Americans as both wars did and nobody
went to prison.
Not One of those guys was prosecuted.
The people responsible for the collapse
of our economy.
Nothing happened to those guys.
And you could argue they kill just as
many people as,
you know,
our enemies did overseas.
And there's a real injustice there.
Well,
I think most people aren't even aware of
how screw the whole thing was.
And there's a great documentary that I
always recommend to people called an
inside job.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
When that guy's starts questioning those
economics professors,
those are the guys who eventually got
jobs in the government and he went from
there and got jobs at big corporations
and you see them like folding,
folding under the weight of the actual
truth of what they've done.
Yeah.
It's
what was disturbing.
I mean,
listen,
there were,
I mean there were,
there were companies that were getting
bailed out by the taxpayer to the tune
of billions of dollars,
right?
Bailed out and the head,
the corporate leaders,
they corporate heads of those companies
who had bankrupted their countries and
ask the country to bail them out while
they were getting bailed out.
These men were taking year end bonuses
of 10,
20,
$30,000,000.
Yeah.
It was stunning.
And then they were trying to put a cap
on the bonuses,
like instead of removing it,
they were going to put a cap on the
bonus cap of 20 million.
Right.
It's just,
it's insane.
St.
Right.
So you,
you think about that and um,
in,
in you makes you feel.
It makes me feel like we don't really
have a country,
like an entity it group that isn't
willing to defend itself isn't really a
group.
Right.
We were attacked by,
in some ways,
we were attacked by those people
economically,
right?
The actions of those people,
the selfserving actions have a very
small number of people cost this
country.
$14,000,000,000,000,
right?
There were no consequences for those
people.
They're actually rewarded and it makes a
person think like,
wow,
is there,
is there something,
is there something called America like
the United States like innocent in the
sense that we'll defend ourselves if
we're attacked.
I mean,
that's one of the definitions of a
country,
of a group and we didn't defend
ourselves.
And so you saw in the recent election,
this sort of,
um,
the confusion in the,
in the population about what it means to
be an American.
Like who?
Like what,
what do we belong to here?
Like what do we owe our loyalty to an
enormous amount of confusion and,
and,
and in my opinion,
it's,
it's increasing,
not decreasing right now in the current
administration,
but it comes from some of those
questions like we're in two that no
one's paying attention to.
We,
you know,
we lost $14,000,000,000,000
and nobody blinked.
Like what is it that we belong to and
what is it?
Yeah,
I mean,
we do seem to be in a deep state of
confusion and I think one of the things
you're seeing with people even like
trump supporters,
people,
uh,
that are these online fraud people,
you know,
the little frog avatars,
I think one of the things that they like
about it is that becomes,
they become a part of a troublesome,
a little group.
Oh,
totally.
Yeah.
They have a sense of purpose.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
why do you think people join isis?
I mean these European,
you know,
people in Europe joining Isis.
Yeah.
They want a sense of purpose and you
know,
they've been taken in by the propaganda
and all that.
They don't realize it's a completely
bloodthirsty,
horrible criminal group,
but,
but they want a sense of meaning,
a sense of purpose.
There was a,
um,
great band from out here about 15 years
ago called called Queens of the Stone
Age.
Sure.
Love those guys.
You amazing.
Right?
And one of the lines line in one of
their songs started to quote rock lyrics
to you,
but one of the lines is,
um,
she wanted something to die for it and
make it beautiful to live.
Something like that.
That's a very profound insight into what
makes people feel like they're leading a
worthy life.
Yeah.
Instead of walking through a nerfed
world.
Yeah.
It's like what we're doing.
Right.
So PROZAC.
So if you walk around and ask people in
the street,
what would you die for?
Like,
who,
or what idea would you die for?
I mean,
people wouldn't,
you know,
they,
they wouldn't have an answer for most of
human history,
you know,
the immediate answer would be,
well,
I die for my people.
Right?
Of course,
like this and this.
Our encampment gets attacked by the
enemy.
I would die.
I would die defending this place,
you know,
and,
and know that no one has that answer,
right?
And,
and,
and which is shows that we live in
safety and luxury,
which is lovely,
but it deprives people of a sense of
purpose and meaning not just safety and
luxury,
but this staggering change and what has
been a normal way of living for people
for thousands and thousands of years.
When you were writing this book and you
were thinking about all the ways that
human beings have altered the
environment around them,
did you like,
do you were saying that,
and I've read this before,
the genetics essentially we're riding on
the same genetics that were 10,000
years ago from 20,
25 years.
Um,
or are we going to change that?
Like are we going to become more
compatible with this bizarre and
artificial world that we've created?
Or are we going to get deeper and deeper
depressed?
Are we going to.
Well,
okay,
so our society or culture is changing
way faster than genetic change can
happen.
Right?
So we haven't even adapted genetically
to the advent of agriculture 10,000
years ago.
That's pretty crazy,
right?
So yeah,
and the only way genetic change happens
in a population is that there is a
difference in survival between people
with one trait and people with another
trade.
So,
so if you have a genetic trait and it
leads to you having fewer children,
eventually 10,000
years from now,
people with your genetic trait will tend
to die out because you're leaving fewer.
You're,
you're passing on less DNA to the next
round.
Right?
And if you have a trait that allows you
to raise more children to maturity,
they carry your DNA and then they'll be
more successful.
And that trade tends to spread.
So does human unhappiness.
There's unhappiness lead to lower
fertility rates,
probably not.
You know what I mean?
Like I mean,
often a depression starts in midlife.
Um,
by that time,
most people have a one or two children,
um,
they've passed on their DNA.
So I don't,
it only acts through reproductive rights
is something happened to us then there,
there must be some way where human
beings are going to become going to
become accustomed to this bizarre way.
We're living stacked on top of each
other constantly and traffic.
We are accustomed to it.
I mean,
humans are very adaptive,
adaptable.
I mean,
you know,
people,
you can put people in solitary
confinement in jail and they're not
happy.
They're extremely depressed,
but there it will physically survive for
decades.
Right?
So,
I mean,
evolution doesn't promise happiness.
It doesn't mean that will evolve towards
happiness.
It means that we will adapt so that we
can re reproduce our DNA for the next
generation.
That's all evolution means.
I've always just looked at all this
reliance on electronics and our
fascination with innovation and I've
wondered if that's where we're headed if
we're,
I mean,
it's almost like it's priming us for
some sort of a symbiotic relationship
with machines that were asked.
We become more reliant on technology
stack more and more people into places
make it easier and easier to survive.
That's the one constant is that we're
constantly embedded in technology.
Yes.
I mean,
technology is a tool of like the bow and
Arrow was and,
but,
um,
you know,
keep in mind the,
the segment of the world population
which is deeply intertwined with high
tech is very,
very small.
Most of humanity lives in a pretty
simple and very,
very poor way.
So if you're talking about the human
race as a whole,
I mean,
I'm not talking about southern
California.
I'm in New York City,
one of the human race as a whole,
you know,
all this technology happened yesterday,
right?
I mean it happened 10 years ago,
20 years ago in 20 years is going to be
so,
you know,
whatever.
I mean,
who knows what's coming down the pike.
Um,
but that,
that's not even a blanket of an,
of an eye in evolutionary terms.
It doesn't even exist.
I mean,
it's,
evolution happens over the course of 10,
20,000
years.
Now when you living this life,
when you are a war journalist and urine,
these insane places,
and then you come back to New York City,
what kind of like a decompression period
do you have to go through?
Well,
you know,
often the,
the developing world that I've worked
in,
I'm no longer covering wars by the way,
but by the developing world is often a
very chaotic urban mix of,
you know,
poverty and cars and,
and pollution and buildings that are
you,
whatever.
I mean it,
it is not necessarily not urban.
Um,
uh,
but what I,
what I would say is that there's a,
um,
there's something I would describe as a
kind of disappointment to have the,
the,
if you wake up in the morning and your
survival is a kind of question mark and
you know,
that you have to act well and,
and,
and with,
with sort of clarity and precision and
quickness in order to survive.
That is intoxicating,
right?
The challenge of that is intoxicating
and you feel like you're sort of in a
way earning your existence and when you
leave that it's a relief,
but it's also a disappointment and
because you're no longer earning
anything,
right?
So it's a relief,
but it's also kind of disappointing and
in that disappointment you can get quite
depressed.
So I know that the depression rate,
like when Pete Been Peace Corps
volunteers come back from two years
service overseas,
they're not in war zones,
but they're in the developing world,
are living in small communities.
They're living at a much more difficult,
physically difficult existence than
people in our system.
Most people in our society,
when they come back to America,
the land of cars and everything you
could want in a superstore in a
supermarket in Nice beds and everything
that you think people want.
When Peace Corps volunteers come back to
this lovely environment,
around 25 percent of them get profoundly
depressed.
Wow.
So clearly what wakes people feel good
is challenged,
not ease.
That's the conclusion I draw.
And not just challenged,
but challenged in the context of a
community of people.
Um,
here we have ease in the,
in,
in the context of oneself or one's
individual family,
but not in the context of the community.
And so,
you know,
if you look at catastrophes,
Hurricane Katrina was just in
Mississippi and I was amazed,
not amazed actually in some ways to have
people have many people say,
well,
we really Miss Hurricane Katrina.
We were all so close afterwards,
you know,
is this a society with a lot of racial
division and all kinds of stuff.
None of that mattered after Hurricane
Katrina.
Everyone cooperated,
everyone helped each other,
make people feel great.
That's what human beings want.
So what we've done by making things too
safe,
we've,
we've dropped off the hills and just
made everything flat and people long for
those hills,
absolutely.
There's a group of friends that I have
that are bow hunters and one of the
things that people have gotten really
addicted to his solo hunting where even
regular bow hunting is not quite
difficult enough for these psychos.
So they go deep,
deep,
20 miles plus into the wilderness by
themselves.
And one of the things they say about it
as how profoundly lonely and sad it is.
And even though they know they could
walk those 20 plus miles back anytime
they want,
but there's something about being out
there by themselves that when they do
return,
they just feel invigorated and alive and
energized and they feel like they've
accomplished something,
especially if they come back with an
animal.
Yeah.
Well listen to me,
that's an ancient narrative,
right?
I mean,
the hunter goes out and kills game and
brings it back and feeds his people.
I mean,
that's a beautiful story.
And it is kept human beings alive for
offered on hundreds of thousands of
years.
You know,
some hunting is well done in groups and
some hunting is a solo enterprise
depending on the animal.
And there absolutely is a role for that
sort of Solo endeavor.
Scouts are often work by themselves
because I mean,
in a native and native context,
um,
like for example,
the American Indians scouts often work
by themselves because they were just
harder to detect.
And if Tara,
I'm sure a terrifying endeavor,
um,
but you're doing it for your people and
so you,
you come back from that,
um,
that solo experience,
which is so frightening.
I mean,
we're social species,
so being alone in a and in danger is
terrifying.
You come back from that to your
community.
You've served your community and your
among your people.
Again,
I must be completely intoxicating.
I envy those people.
That experience.
Yeah,
just having the experience of being in
danger and then coming back and being at
peace makes you appreciate that piece,
but constantly and consistently being at
peace has a numbing effect.
That's right.
It's like constantly and consistently
being well fed.
I mean,
I mean it.
It's not bad to feel hungry once in a
while.
Then you really appreciate food,
safety,
food,
warmth.
I'm being rested or tired.
I mean w w,
w,
w were adapted to to get through
situations where we don't have enough of
what we want,
what we need and if we,
if we're not deprived of those things,
we stop appreciating them and those
things are what make up life so we're
actually losing.
We're losing our appreciation,
our enjoyment of the things that make
life what it is.
And it was a real irony there.
There is a real irony there.
Did you feel compelled at all to come up
with a solution,
I mean in deeply describing and just
going over the various aspects of these
problems that we're facing as a culture,
as a society?
Did you,
did you have some sort of a lead?
I didn't.
I mean,
listen,
if I thought,
if there was a solution that I was
capable of thinking of,
I would have put it in the book.
Either I'm not smart enough or there's
no solution.
I don't know what it is.
Yeah.
I think there's some things we can do
around the edges that will help.
Um,
but we're talking about a systemic
problem in society that has,
that has that got it's start 10,000
years ago and really got it started.
The industrial revolution and really got
really got going into the technological
revolution.
You're knocking,
I mean,
we're not going to ban the car,
right?
The Amish in Pennsylvania don't use
cars.
They have a very low rate of suicide and
depression because they spend most of
their lives within their community,
right?
That buffers that are from suicide and
depression,
we're not going to abandon the car,
right?
We're not going to burn down the
suburbs,
living lean tos.
We'd probably be happier if we did,
but we're not going to do it.
So.
But what can we do?
The biggest that we have is the nation
is the country.
And I think one thing that would help
enormously is to treat our nation as if
we all belong to it and as if we all
respected it and that it was meaningful
to all of us.
And which means among other things,
it means insisting that politicians who
denigrate,
um,
who denigrate other other politicians
who denigrate segments of the
population,
who rank American citizens in terms of
value,
in terms of being quote,
American,
whatever that means.
Politicians who do that are undermining
our sense of national community.
And I think that has a trickle down
effect,
which is extremely demoralizing and
makes,
gives you the equivalent of feeling
like,
wow,
if you're feeling like you're a child in
a family that might,
with the parents might get divorced.
I remember during the campaign between
Donald and Hilary,
I sort of felt like,
wow,
or mom and dad split up like this
happening in this country.
You know what I mean?
Like,
okay,
you can argue,
but you guys are really talking as if
the country's not going to stay
together.
Yeah,
that's terrifying.
I think it's extremely demoralizing and
unsettling for people.
Well,
it's also extremely irresponsible,
like the type of person that should be a
leader.
It's not the type of person that puts
that idea out there to the point where
it gets into the zeitgeists and people
say,
well,
hey wait,
maybe we really are in trouble.
Well exactly.
I mean I think,
I think it it fearmongering it is.
And,
and you know,
these are ancient human behaviors and if
you tell your people that there's a
threat,
your people will rally behind you.
I mean,
it's an,
it's an adaptive behavior,
right?
The problem is,
as a politician,
if you tell your people that the enemy
is actually the other political party,
you are effectively splitting the
country and so you can act tribally all
you want.
I mean,
tribal tribalism has a very negative
connotation as well.
You can act in that tribal way all you
want,
as long as you define your tribe as the
country,
the entire country.
Right?
And if you start slicing off group parts
of the country,
demographic groups in the country,
political groups in the country,
so you know,
you're actually not really American,
like you really shouldn't be part of
this.
When you start doing that,
you destroy the country.
You're way more of a threat to our
democracy than,
than Isis and al Qaeda is.
I mean,
we,
we're such a powerful country.
We're the only force that can destroy
us.
No one else can touch us.
They can hurt us.
So they can't really destroy us.
We can destroy us and we can,
we can,
we will destroy ourselves through
rhetoric.
Who was one of the things that was most
disturbing about the debates when Donald
Trump said that if Hillary Clinton won,
he wouldn't necessarily accept the
decision.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
he was being a co that was completely
antithetical to the,
uh,
to democracy and to the,
um,
to the concept of a country,
to the concept of a democratic country.
I absolutely,
because he's a part of it.
So if she becomes the president,
she's his president and we're all
supposed to look at the president as
this is the one person that we've
elected as leader and what he's
essentially saying it's either
me or nothing.
That's right.
And what,
and what I really am.
I'm a democrat.
I didn't vote for Donald Trump.
Um,
but I really didn't like it when some of
my fellow Democrats after he was elected
and he was elected,
right?
I mean,
one way or another.
Uh,
I mean,
if you can investigate Russia if you
want or whatever,
but,
but the fact is that he,
he got the most electoral votes and he's
our president and I really disliked it
when my,
some of my fellow Democrats said,
he's not my president.
He is actually.
And if you don't like that,
work harder next time and get someone
else elected.
But he gives you a president.
And,
and it was equally disgusting when the
shoe was on the other foot with Barack
Obama and some conservatives started
saying that Barack Obama wasn't really
American,
or he wasn't really their president or
that he was an enemy of the state,
that he was a secret Muslim spy.
He wanted to destroy Manchurian
candidate.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
it's totally irresponsible and,
and it's antithetic.
It's the opposite of patriotism and it's
revolting.
Do you think in that case it may be.
It's good that we have a guy like Donald
Trump and the president because he is
kind of like almost like a human
hurricane.
He's something to rally against.
He's a,
a problem that's occurred where there's
the eroding confidence in the president
now.
I mean,
it's palpable.
People know he lies.
He lies all the time.
I mean,
he just accused James Comey today of
lying under oath when he talked about
their conversations.
You know,
I think Donald Trump is a very damaged
and unhealthy person.
I think he causes a lot of pain to
people around him.
And I,
I'm,
I'm guessing that he's in an enormous
amount of,
of psychic pain himself,
sense for all the hate tweets and all
the things we constantly going after
Rosie O'donnell and why?
I mean,
what I've learned in my life is that if
someone's acting badly,
they're in pain.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's a really simple rule,
right?
They're either scared or they're in
pain.
I think he's both.
And on some level I feel kind of a kind
of compassion for him.
But what I,
what I mean he's,
he,
he's,
he already is and will be a completely
failed president,
but he may actually help this country in
his failure.
Um,
the gop I think has abandoned all of its
core values and core moral principles
and decided that seems to have decided
that anything that will help the party
is more important than things that will
help the country.
And that is a very,
very undemocratic way to think.
Um,
I think if,
if Hillary Clinton had been elected and
these things were coming out,
the same kind of things about Russia,
et Cetera,
are coming out,
the gop would be crossing her,
prosecuting her up to her eyeballs,
right?
So they have a complete double standard.
And what I'm hoping is that the trump
administration is such a failure that it
gets the gop to reevaluate its policy of
partisan politics as a way to wind
power.
And I hope it makes the entire country
realize that the only way to really wind
power is through bipartisan politics.
And you can argue all you want,
but you have to.
You have to put the welfare of the
country first.
I read an amazing book called our
political selves.
I think it was called,
um,
that about half of our political opinion
is jen is genetically determined.
So genetically determined.
Yeah.
So,
and it,
which makes sense.
So liberalism and conservatism,
basically liberalism is concerned with
fairness within the group and equality
within the group and an acceptance of
outsiders as possible for possible
inclusion in the group.
Conservatism is focused on hierarchy and
sort of law and order and a suspicion of
outsiders and they're very,
very powerful evolutionary,
adaptive evolutionary reasons for both
of those worldviews.
And they've done studies with identical
twins that were adopted at birth and
compared them to fraternal twins and
there's a far higher concordance of a
political opinion in identical twins
that were adopted at birth and put in
different kinds of families than with
fraternal twins.
So that means that our political,
apparently it's around 50 percent of our
political beliefs,
are genetically determined,
which means that those beliefs had
adaptive value in,
uh,
in our evolutionary past,
which means that the argument,
I'm right,
you're completely wrong and you
shouldn't exist,
is a false argument,
is that the country actually needs both
parties very,
very badly.
And that a healthy society has
conservatism and liberalism in a kind of
dynamic tension where yes,
they might fight,
they might argue,
but they are there roughly proportional
in the population and equal weight is
given to those two.
Competing values
wasn't taken into consideration that
when these people are adopted,
that growing up,
adopted without your biological parents,
puts you in a certain mindset
automatically and that maybe it wasn't
necessarily a genetic thing,
but it was a circumstantial or nurture.
Well,
they compared identical twins who are
genetically identical,
of course,
that were adopted to fraternal twins who
were adopted.
You understand?
Yes,
and fraternal twins are not genetically
identical,
but they still come from the same body
they used to come to.
Their DNA is different individuals.
Right.
So both sets of twins were adopted,
so they all went through that.
Whatever that is,
that,
that process,
the effects of that,
whatever they are.
One our one shared DNA,
exact duplicates of their DNA.
The other set of twins don't.
They're fraternal.
So the,
the,
the twins that shared identical DNA,
we're far more likely to have the same
political beliefs than the fraternal
twins.
In other words,
the genetic component was influencing
their beliefs and the environmental
component was not as much compared to
the fraternal twins is an amazing book
and it really,
to me,
it makes sense,
like both worldviews clearly were needed
to keep our society healthy and strong
and safe.
I mean,
God,
a country that was run completely by
liberals would get overrun by,
you know,
the enemy state next door immediately,
right?
A country that was completely run by
conservatives would never get overrun by
the enemy,
but it will be a heartless and brutal
society where the poor weren't taken
care of and etc.
Etc.
So you can't havE one or the other.
You need both.
The kind of dynamic tension.
So it makes genetic sense that it works
that way.
JuSt like there would be genetic
variations and all sorts of different
aspects of people,
height and personality and all those
different things.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's sore character traits,
right?
I mean,
they're partly genetic and they're
partly determined by experience.
So,
um,
you know,
courage or whatever,
generosity,
a sensation seeking,
right?
A is a genetic trait.
Um,
but you can,
you can your,
since your impulse towards sensation
seeking is also determined by your
experiences in life.
Right?
I don't know what the proportions are,
but in terms of political belief,
it's roughly 50 slash 50.
Your experience in life is about 50
percent responsible for your political
beliefs and the,
and the other 50 percent is genetics.
We're always looking for one reason,
right?
We're always looking for nature or
nurture.
We'll looking for one of.
We're not looking at this just whole
soup of different entangled influences
that create a person.
Yeah.
And it's really interesting when I tell
people that their genetics determine
half of their political view,
they get really upset,
right?
They want to be completely
self-determining,
right?
I mean that people want to think that
they are completely w whatever they are,
they've created themselves and certainly
something as emotional as political
belief.
They don't want to think that is wired
into their dna at all.
But You know,
that's,
that's the truth of it.
Well,
just determinism in general.
I mean,
I remember the first time it was ever
really deeply explained to me by sam
harris.
I was rejecting it like almost instant
of realizing I was like,
I didn't want to just be open minded
about it.
I wanted to go to aa,
na.
You could pull yourself up.
You could figure it out.
Yeah.
You do whaT your,
your willpower.
You decide what you want to do with your
life,
but not really necessarily.
I mean,
listen,
when I was young I was a really good
distance runner.
Right?
And I ran the half mile mile at up to
10,000
meters marathon,
whatever,
ran 4:12
for the mile,
which is a pretty decent time and it's
very fast.
I really wanted it to be like the
fastest miler in the world.
Right.
And I trained as fast as anyone who's
ever trained as,
as hard as anyone's ever trained and I
might.
My ceiling was poor 12.
I mean that was genetically determined.
No,
sorry.
Like you can run 130 miles a week like I
did for months on end and still not go
to the olympics.
Yeah,
there's no doubt about it may not as a
mixed martial arts commentator,
the the big factor that you can't do
anything about his power.
Some people are born with striking power
and it doesn't make any sense.
They have,
they look exactly the Same.
They look just like a person who can't
hit nearly as hard as them.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I mean my understanding is the sort of
sequencing of muscle groups in
coordination that result in that kind of
power is amazing.
It's bone structure as well.
There's a level of variables is actually
the,
the geometry of the shoulder,
like how wide your shoulders are in
terms of the
hip to waist ratio.
There's a lot of different factors.
Kidding.
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons why men can
hit so much harder than women is
literally the shape of the hips.
women's hips are wider,
the the legs go inward more.
It's a different sort of mechanical
advantage which is probably connected to
the speed.
You can throw a baseball at the same
skeletal.
Yeah.
Apparently boys and girls can throw
pretty much the same until puberty and
then it really splits,
um,
and uh,
and so it's probably for that reason I
will.
That'd be interesting.
Like to see what they do with
transgender women to men who start
taking testosterone.
I don't think it changes the shape of
your pelvis.
No,
I mean the testosterone doesn't,
you know,
isn't going to change your.
It does,
it does.
It does have some effects on bone
density and I think the width of the
shoulders changes and certain
characters,
the face obviously changes.
Yeah,
right.
yeah.
And Just the sort of muscle explosive
power of the muscles.
Then as you get old you lose explosive
power as a man.
Right.
So,
I mean testosterone,
historic key.
You're,
I mean,
you're,
you're at your peak in your early
twenties,
I guess.
Yeah.
But anyway,
what we're saying is that there really
are genetic limitations.
There's no doubt about it.
And this idea of like a fair fight.
There's sometimes it's not fair.
It's just not going to be.
And a with you as the mile with some
people.
It's the,
the ability to hit hard.
It's some people,
it's just speed,
you know,
I mean if you've ever seen like a floyd
mayweather fight is incredibly clear
that not only is he ridiculously
skillful,
but he's got some stupendous speed
advantage over most human beings.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
I also,
I was watching his fight of his,
it was sort of slow mo.
I mean I sort of slowed it down so I
could really watch and he got hit full
in the face by somebody I mean,
right in the face and his,
his eyes never blink.
Yeah.
Like he,
I mean he couldn't get out of the way
and he watched that thing come in and
hit him square in the face and his eyes
never closed.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
Really good.
Boxers can do that.
As they're getting punched in their
face,
their eyes are wide open and they're
looking for the counter.
It's really incredible.
It's amazing.
No flinch at all.
I mean,
nothing.
Absolutely nothing amount of training
you would have to do to overcome the
end.
It's one of the most,
one of them.
More important reasons why it's so
critical to learn striking in particular
at a very young age,
the body develops,
some people can pick it up later in life
and still be really successful at it,
but I don't think you ever really get
like a real elite boxer that doesn't
start training before puberty or around
puberty.
You're probably right now,
there's just something about the
development of the body,
like your body growing and maturing with
this task,
learning how to strike and move and
explode with combinations.
Likewise for music and languages,
and if you're not learning that before
puberty,
you will never be like at a top,
top,
top world class level.
Ah,
that makes sense.
in terms of languages,
you will not be able to speak with a
perfect exit.
Really?
Yup.
After puberty,
the,
the brain is finished wiring itself and
it cannot.
It cannot exactly mimic a foreign accent
and if you learn french or whatever at
any language that you know,
eight,
nine,
10,
you can sound exactly like a native and
after puberty you can.
Wow.
Do you have kids?
Yes.
I have a three and a half month old
daughter.
Well,
when they start talking to you,
man,
that's when it gets weird.
Um,
I have,
uh,
three,
29 and a seven.
And uh,
what's,
what's really fascinating is watching
the,
um,
the traits that you know,
have come directly from dna,
like parts of you emerge out of the kid
and maybe one kid and then the other
kid,
none of it,
you know,
and some of it will be your wife and
it's just,
it's so strange to.
You try to piece it together.
Like what,
what our instincts,
right.
Why are,
why are dogs barking at snakes?
They don't know what the fuck a snake
is,
but they know something's wrong.
There's something deep in their memorY
banks and say this is an issue.
Whereas a stuffed animal on the ground
is not an issue.
Right?
Yeah,
that's rIght.
That's right.
We don't know what that is entirely.
Well,
I tell you what it is,
is that the dogs that weren't
reflexively fearful of something that
looked like a snake died more often
produce offspring,
and so they'll bark at a crooked stick
to just to be on the safe side.
And you know,
likewise,
humans are scared of heights.
Um,
yeah,
there's a,
if you're not scared of heights,
you're more likely to fall and you won't
pass on your genes.
I'm lucy,
the famous early,
early human skeleton in,
in east africa.
I don't know.
I mean,
you do know lucy from your science
classes.
Yeah.
Um,
she died by falling out of a tree.
Wow.
Yeah.
They just figured that out from the
fractures and stuff and her bone
structure.
Wow.
Yeah.
That must have been incredibly common.
It's just all the different things that
people are afraid of.
Arachnophobia video phobia,
fear of spiders and snakes.
I mean those are directly related to
poison.
I'm terrified of spiders.
So you feel as genetic,
like maybe someone in
past or somewhat.
Well,
I tell you,
I mean the,
the range of things that,
the common phobias that people have,
those,
those things have a,
have a sort of survival significance,
right?
So people usually aren't phobIc of
chairs because chairs,
we're not a survival threat in our
evolutionary past,
but heights,
spiders,
snakes,
uh,
those kinds of things.
We're a,
we're a threat.
And so when children get phobias,
they're choosing something that makes
genetic sense.
Yes.
Why I chose spiders,
I don't know,
I was just exposed to it.
Frightening spider at the wrong moment
in my insecure little life.
Do you think you were
opposed to it or you think maybe is it
possible that someone in your past to
some ancestor so far passed that through
the dna?
Well,
I mean,
we're all predisposed towards being.
I'm a reasonably fearful of those
things,
right?
A phobia is a panic disorder,
so we're all nervous around.
I'm barking dogs,
snakes,
spiders,
heights,
those kinds of things,
right?
Um,
be claustrophobia and being trapped in a
small space,
that's all normal things to be worried
about,
but when it crosses the threshold to a
phobia,
that's a panic disorder.
And that is a function of something
going on in your childhood where,
but is it absolutely in your childhood?
I mean,
phobia start in childhood yet,
but I mean is it possible that someone
could have a video phobia arachnophobia
and not have experienced spiders or
snakes?
It's one of the things that happened to
me when I was hosting fear factor as I
would see people that were pretty risk
taking.
They were and they would,
they would be willing to do the heights.
They would be willing to jump a car off
the top of a building.
They would take chances.
They were risk takers,
but you'd put them in front of a snake
and they would freak the fuck out.
And it was,
it was a deep cellular thing,
like you could see with some people
that,
that they weren't cowards,
they weren't timid folks.
Right.
But they would see that one thing,
whatever that thing is.
Right.
Well,
I,
you know,
I don't know,
I,
I will tell you though that once I don't
have a television,
but I was in a hotel like I watch tv
when I'm traveling because I'm in a
hotel and I saw fear factor and they're.
And so keep in mind,
I've been terrified of spiders my entire
life and there was one.
I mean this was actually quite
traumatizing to me.
I mean seriously,
like traumatizing,
like it affected me for days.
There was like a very hot young woman in
a bikini and you put her in a glass,
like a glass box and you dumped a 55
gallon drum of tranches onto her.
Yeah.
I remember that her boyfriend threw up,
it was so and she finally stood up with
tarantulas,
fallen off her.
I mean she couldn't take it and I was
like in the fetal position in the corner
of my hotel room.
Wow.
Yeah.
It waS totally horrifying to me.
I mean,
it really messed me up for a few days.
It's just so strange that there's
particular things that resonate like
that,
like particular things,
whether it's a snake or a spider,
just a.
I mean,
I really wonder if like the things that
human beings have and that also animals
have these instincts.
If we just don't totally understand what
memory is,
we don't totally understand genetic
memories,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
it's all stuff that,
that helped us survive.
Those are all threats in our,
in our primordial passed.
Now you've got a,
a documentary out that you're working on
as well.
Uh,
well it's out.
No,
it's airing on sunday.
It's,
um,
it's called hell on earth.
It's about the syrian civil war and the
rise of isis and it's out on national
geographic channel nine eastern and
central,
uh,
this sunday,
this sunday.
Um,
is it going to be available?
I mean,
you can obviously watch it at the time,
but it's going to be available on
netflix or apple tv or something like
that where I don't know that.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
I haven't even thought that far ahead.
I mean it's owned by national,
so I don't know quite know how they're.
I'm sure you'll be able to get it on
their website at some point,
but it's airing on sunday.
And what was your experience doing that?
Well,
you know,
I was home writing tribe actually.
And so I wasn't overseas and you
couldn't really get into Syria anyway.
I mean it was a suicidal thing to do.
Um,
and uh,
so what we did,
my colleague nick,
the guy who was here earlier,
um,
we basically sort of work the border
border areas around Syria.
I'm looking for people who were living
in Syria who knew people in Syria who
could shoot for us and we found some
very,
very brave people who documented their
lives under isis,
their lives with the free syrian army.
There was a lot of combat.
Um,
and we accumulated about an hour,
a thousand hours of footage and
interviews we did with experts and we
put together a hell on earth trying to
explain how really quite peaceful
democratic protests,
um,
turn into violent demonstrations and
finally into a civil war.
And of course it's the,
it was the repressive government.
I mean,
people protest in the street and they're
met with machine gun fire and eventually
civilians are going to get some machine
guns themselves and fight back and
that's how you get a civil war.
How do you take thousands of hours like
that and boil it down to a one show?
YeAh.
Well that's,
it's very,
very hard.
Um,
uh,
I mean,
that's what filmmaking is and it's
figuring out what's the one percent that
goes into the film and how do I
structure it?
Um,
how much time does it take to do
something?
We had a really good.
I mean,
this is the first I've made.
This is my fifth film.
Most of the films I've made,
it was me and an editor and so another
person in the room or whatever,
this.
We had a big team.
And so we had some very,
very smart yoUng people who are going
through all this footage and
categorizing it.
Like,
here,
this is a section about,
you know,
this material is about whatever,
escaping isis and this is about trying
to find whatever they would.
They would sort of put it into
categories and then I would start to
look through some of that material and
congratulate,
sort of build a,
build a structure,
the,
um,
the situation in Syria seems to be a,
for someone who just hasn't studied it
that much,
but just looks at it from the outside.
One of the bleaker darker situations
that we have here in the world.
I mean,
it's the tragic tragedy of this
generation.
I think,
uh,
over 400,000
syrians,
mostly civilians have died.
The equivalent equivalent death toll in
this country would be,
I think seven or $8 million americans.
These are equivalent amount of people.
Um,
and,
and half the country,
half the syrian population has been
displaced from their homes and millions,
millions or,
uh,
you know,
outside the country's borders in europe
and,
and even in this country.
What did you take out of the
documentary?
I mean,
it seems like no one has a solution for
Syria.
No,
I mean,
civil wards are tough that way.
Um,
I think isis,
isis eventually is going to be defeated
on the battlefield.
Um,
they're going to be eradicated.
And I hope they are because they're a
ghastly,
brutal group m and a side who is,
who's killed way more people than isis.
He just didn't do it publicly like they
did.
Um,
he's the leader of Syria,
the president of Syria,
he,
he's propped up by Iran and by Russia.
And so he's not going anywhere.
I mean,
if you have those two countries as your
allies,
like you're not going anywhere.
So I think what's going to happen
ultimately is that isis will be defeated
and the country will be partitioned
along sectarian lines and they're
eventually.
There may be a kind of a delicate piece.
It seems like with all those middle
eastern countries or any country that's
run by a brutal dictator,
as soon as that dictators removed or as
soon as somebody dies,
there's this massive power vacuum.
Yeah.
I mean that would be the argument for
not trying to remove them.
I mean,
he's a complete criminal and sadist and
um,
by these horrible.
But yeah.
Was the argument for keeping saddam
hussein in power?
It was the argument for keeping kadafi
and power.
Yeah.
I mean,
basically it's sort of utilitarian
argument from jaws doraville like what's
gonna,
what's gonna cause the least human
suffering or promote the most human
happiness and,
and,
uh,
you know,
sometimes,
um,
I can understand the reasoning behind,
look,
the guy's a dictator,
but we should leave him in place because
the alternative is a lot of other
innocent people suffering when we remove
him in the country collapses,
this country has already collapsed.
So the pro is,
or the question is,
okay,
we make a tentative peace deal with him.
We'll leave you empower.
We won't try to topple you.
Um,
but let's stop fighting.
I mean,
I can,
I,
I could support that.
Yeah.
Personally.
Wow.
Crazy.
The idea of keeping that guy in power
just so less people suffer and you keep
a brutal murder as dictator in power.
Yeah.
And we're better off that way.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
the war killed almost half a million
people,
so if you want to,
if you want that to continue,
I mean those are the awful moral
choices.
Um,
it's very frustrating for people though
because it would like to see.
We'd like to see some solution like on
the tape,
but that doesn't seem
well,
it's a solution to the violence.
I mean,
any,
any peace deal is a solution to the
violence.
So.
And the first thing that has to happen I
think is that the violence stops so that
people stop dying.
Um,
the pursuit of justice,
it is a secondary is important,
but it's a secondary matter after that.
W,
I know you're running out of time here,
so I'm good.
What,
what brings you,
what brings you satisfaction when you,
when you do something like this
documentary or,
or your book tribe?
Yeah,
I really like the,
I liked the sort of game of ideas,
right?
Like I like exploring a topic and
starting to make sense of it and
starting to see connections between
things.
So when I was writing tribe,
we'd started the,
the,
when the central thesis of it sort of
occurred to me and all these disparate
suddenly align themselves in an orderly
way.
And I felt like I'd shown a little bit
of light onto the woRld and shown how it
works.
Like that's totally intoxicating to me.
And likewise,
when you're making your documentary,
you suddenly start to see themes and
structures in the film,
in human affairs that they,
they sort of come out and,
and,
and when it and when you work on that
level,
it's incredible.
To me it's like an incredibly gratifying
and that because that means that I've
now made sense of something.
There's a disorderly,
confusing world and I've managed to
organize it in an understandable way and
that means other people can understand
it and then we can have a conversation
about how the world works and how people
work.
And that to me is the point of
journalism is the point of all
intellectual endeavor.
And,
and to be even a small part of it to me
is incredibly exciting.
Well,
you nailed it and you,
you definitely nailed it.
And with this the thing I was talking
about how when it just beginning the
first chapter,
I had a real urge to get out of the
city.
I had a real urge to like,
there's this thought like,
could I live in the woods?
Can I live in a tribal society?
Like,
it seems,
it seems like you were outlining like a,
almost like a mathematical problem.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
it,
um,
or chemical,
maybe even a chemical problem.
Well,
you know,
I studied anthropology in college and to
my understanding of humans is that we
are social.
We are social primates that prefer to
live in groups of about 50 people in a,
in a challenging environment.
That's what human beings are.
And uh,
to the extent that we depart from that,
we,
uh,
lead lives of dissatisfaction and um,
and frustration.
And that's how I understand life.
How do you manage that in your own life?
I,
um,
I mean,
I wish I,
you know,
I wish I was part of a communal group
fighting to survive in the wilderness.
Like,
I mean,
I,
I had some taste of that with the
platoon that I was with and that was
intoxicating.
It has downsides obviously.
And uh,
uh,
you can't stay out there forever,
but,
um,
it may be at least understand that the
source of my dissatisfaction in life
wasn't internal.
It was,
it made sense.
It was that I was having a healthy
reaction to circumstances in society
that,
that humans were not adapted for,
and even that was enough to bring a kind
of peace of mind for me.
Um,
I also very consciously and deliberately
try to live in places where there is the
possibility of,
of um,
uh,
sort of close communal neighborhood.
I live in a very poor neighborhood in
New York city at which for some of the
hassles at least has the sort of rich
fabric of human connection that you just
don't get in wealthy neighborhoods.
So you do it on purpose.
Oh yeah.
What I don't want to say,
where do you want to say where you live?
I live in lower east side manhattan and
um,
he's not very,
very poor,
but it's,
it is a dominican,
dominican neighborhood.
Have half the people in that
neighborhood really don't speak english
very well.
So it's not very,
it's a very rich or ethnic neighborhood.
People are quite poor.
Um,
and I,
and I know everybody and everyone knows
each other by sight and we look out for
each other and it's during hurricane,
a hurricane.
When hurricane sandy hit New York,
I mean a lot of the people that had
young children had to leave because
there was no light,
there was no water or the power was out
right to half of manhattan was
completely dark and it was really
actually quite dangerous at night in the
dark half of manhattan and uh,
where there was no streetlights and um,
so this building,
it's a tenement building that I live in
with my wife and um,
and a lot of the people left and the,
the,
they were worried about being robbed and
these are poor people,
right?
This is not a wealthy building at all,
is quite,
quite poor building.
And so they,
they,
they organized a guard shift.
One of the people,
one of the women in the building had a
machete and they organized guard shifts
at the front door with a machete and the
young,
the young men in the building took turns
to like two hours at a time guarding the
building with a machete.
Yeah.
And um,
you know,
I wasn't associated with the building at
that time,
but boy would that have made me feel
good to be part of that,
that,
you know what I mean,
like that is what human beings,
that's what they are.
Is that right?
And you didn't see that in a wealthy
neighborhood,
partly because the wealthy neighborhoods
actually had light just seems weird to
make the choice to live in a community
like that because of those factors.
Well,
my wife lived there and I moved in with
her,
so,
uh,
but,
but the,
the reason I was happy to move in with
her,
one of the reasons I was happy to move
in with her is precisely because it
wasn't an affluent neighborhood,
like the kind I grew up in.
That to me is just sold death.
Right.
I mean it just,
I grew up in an affluent suburb and it's
just the most boring thing on the
planet.
Like it's deadlY to me.
And,
and I,
you know,
like had I not grown up like that,
maybe I'd be living in a neighborhood
like that.
I mean,
I get it right,
but I did grow up like that and the one
thing that I just cannot survive is that
kind of complacent affluence.
Like it just kills me.
It's so funny because that's the one
thing that people try to achieve when
they grow up in that sort of poor
community.
They want to get out and live in a big
house.
The big yard.
Look at their suicide rates,
their addiction rates,
their depression rates.
I mean,
seriously,
if you,
uh,
if you look at those,
alcoholism,
depression,
suicide in affluent neighborhoods,
I mean,
it's astronomical.
It's brutal boy,
but try to convince people to abandon
that way.
That's where it's really odd.
It seems like,
so counter intuitive to them.
It's like,
no,
you're going to live in a safe
neighborhood.
No,
no,
no.
You're going to have a big house.
You gonna have a nice car and a great
job.
You're going to do great.
Well,
think about an evolutionary terms,
terms.
The impulse towards safety and luxury is
a totally healthy one in a situation
where nature doesn't offer that very
often,
right?
So we're programmed to go for those
things,
right?
What we're not prepared for is to go for
those things and have it happen all the
time.
You see what I'm saying?
Like it's totally healthy instincts of
course.
Right?
But we didn't involve in a world where
you could actually achieve that 100
percent of the time.
I mean,
dogs are programmed,
a lot of dog species or program will
will,
will eat until they've eaten so much
that they'll kill themselves eating.
Right?
It's because there wasn't enough food to
like the programming to keep eating as
long as their food is great.
If there's a scarcity of food,
right?
Right.
As soon as there's a plentitude of food
that becomes maladaptive and the dog
dies and you know,
likewise,
people put fat on very easily because in
a harsh environment with not much food,
you have to be able to put fat on easily
or you'll die.
Now with the.
The reason there's so many obese people
is because we have that impulse to eat
and eat and eat and the foods there to
do it with,
and we don't have the mechanism for
stopping it,
and so that's why there's so many happy.
Oh,
it's also sugar.
That's a big absolutely.
But our taste for sugar and for fat is
programmed by evolution,
right?
Because there wasn't much of those
things,
so now you can have as much as you want
and suddenly people weigh 350 pounds.
Right?
I mean it's,
it's,
it's evolutionary programming.
Run a muck in a world where there's too
much of something that was very good but
was very scarce.
You highlight some really profound
issues with culture in your book,
but I would wonder if how many people
come up to you after they've read it and
go,
what do I do?
Like,
you're right,
but what do I do?
I mean,
here I am.
I'm this guy,
have this house,
I have a mortgage,
I have kids,
I have a job that's good and I don't
want to leave it,
but what do I do?
Because you're right,
I'm fucking miserable.
What do you,
what do I do?
Like,
what do you tell those people?
Um,
I,
I mean,
it really a question of is the question
you can't have it all and I mean what I
would say to them is sell your house,
move in,
sell you car.
If you can move into a community where
you have to be into reliant with the
people around you.
And a,
I have to interact with them everyday.
Like that is what makes people feel
good.
But the thing is people are
understandably not willing to give up
the pleasures of an affluent life in
order to have social connection.
I mean,
I get it right,
but you really can't have both very
successfully.
it's extremely hard to.
Yeah.
Body.
My who lived in venice and a real nice
tight knit community.
They had this called the sac and
everybody lived in the city.
Everyone,
everyone knoW everybody.
I live in a cul de sac right there.
Great.
And he started doing well.
And the first thing he did,
he moved out and you've got this really
nice house in this big yard.
And he fucking hates it and he's
miserable and we talk about it.
He goes,
I fucking hate it.
I don't know my neighbors.
He goes,
I have this big yard.
I just stare at it and go back inside my
house.
He goes,
I used to know everyone on the block.
I knew everyone in the community.
Yeah,
that's right.
Well,
that guy is.
I mean,
that lifestyle is correlated with higher
depression and suicide rates.
I mean,
he's literally a statistical risk,
uh,
increased statistical risk of suicide
and depression because of that change.
Wow.
So you,
regardless of how much money you would
make,
you would always move into a
neighborhood where people are relying
upon each other and tight to each other.
Oh yeah.
I'm not.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
it's not even a.
Yeah,
no way.
Or like,
it's not even a choice.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'd be like,
I just get instantly depressed in
affluent neighborhoods.
Wow.
that's so crazy.
Yeah.
I mean,
I crash.
I mean hard.
Do you accumulate any material
possessions?
Are you.
One of those dudes Was like a notebook
and a couple of pairs of shoes
mean minimally,
but yeah,
I mean we live in a very small apartment
so there's not room for much.
But
uh,
are you happy with that?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean listen,
the less you have,
the happier you are at the end of the
day.
Like you could probably make that as a
empirically true statement.
Empirically.
True.
we really,
and I'm not,
it isn't.
I'm not talking about poverty,
lack of food,
lack of resources.
I mean I'm obviously not talking about
that.
I'm talking about material
possession,
stopped cars and boats and shit.
I always feel like once you get a boat
you're probably falling,
falling apart,
you know what I mean?
Like unless you're a fisherman,
you know,
you're going out there and getting a
boat.
It's like what?
You just,
you know,
what are you doing?
Well,
you know,
it's interesting like that kind of
mature,
those kind of material possessions also.
They mean again,
evolution,
right?
Like a particularly for males in the
society.
If you control resources,
you,
you have a reproductive advantage over
males that don't control resources and
you knoW,
girls will like you better.
Right?
So when you're an 18 year old boy,
the instinct to get a car,
to get a boat baby one day to get a
private area,
you know what a private airplane,
whatever.
That instinct has huge evolutionary
advantage because it gives you access to
women.
Not all women but enough.
So that's a great strategy for meeting
girls,
right?
The problem is that once you're sort of
further on in your life and you have
children,
you have a family,
if you don't have a community and what
you have instead is a huge lawn and
overpowered boat and a ridiculously
expensive car you have.
You have taken things that were,
that were,
that were a definite reproductive
advantage at 18 and you have dragged
them into midlife where instead of
making you feel good,
they will depress you.
In my opinion.
Like that's,
that's What happens to those guys.
So it was not that those things are
still a stupid idea at a earlier point
in your life,
but definitely when you're 50 years old,
again,
I'm sure like you could call if you did
a proper study,
you could,
you could make a correlation between
those kinds of material,
possession at alcohol abuse,
depression,
suicide,
all that stuff.
I wonder if that's the case with like
rappers and people that grow up in these
poor black communities that go onto have
a insane material wealth.
I've always been fascinated by the
ridiculous hip hop culture of just giant
houses and 50 cars and throwing money up
into the air and just this celebration
of excess coming from a place of nothing
and having deep desire
to,
to achieve all those things that seemed
unattainable.
Look,
I mean,
I think athletes have the same problem
too,
you know,
and particularly,
I mean,
they have the fraternity of their team
until they retire and apparently retired
athletes,
professional athletes are real risk of
depression.
Yes.
Um,
and uh,
I mean,
listen,
I met a young woman who had survived
cancer and she said to me rather
sheepishly,
she said,
you know,
when I,
when I was sick,
she was on a cancer ward and she knew
all the other cancer,
suffers service,
suffers on the ward and her family and
her,
it's her.
Basically,
her tribe rallied around her and she
didn't know if she was going to survive,
she would undergoing chemo and all that
awful awful stuff.
And she looked at me sheepishly and said
no,
and I survived and now I missed being
sick.
She missed the community of,
of,
of cancer sufferers on that ward.
And in her own community that rallied
around her.
She,
she was lonely soldiers missing war and
cancer survivors are missing cancer.
Like something's missing.
Yeah.
So the,
well,
there's a struggle that's missing for
sure.
You know,
in my own life,
I'm a,
I'm a very addictive personality,
addictive personality,
and I've found a lot of happiness in a
martial arts.
And one of the things about martial arts
is,
particularlY in jujitsu,
because it's one of the rare martial
arts,
you could practice going 100 percent and
not really hurt each other too much
because you're not,
you're not hitting each other,
right?
You just choking each other and tapping
each other out and stuff.
But this,
there's A camaraderie and a bond between
people that choke each other all the
time that you just don't see with other
men or I don't see.
Well yeah,
listen,
I hear you.
But I,
I mean I started when I,
when my marriage started falling apart,
I started boxing,
right?
And I just needed something.
I'd always been a pretty intense athlete
when I was young that I was starting to
smoke cigarettes and drank for a while
and then suddenly on my life's in crisis
at 15 and I started going to a boxing
gym,
mendez boxing in New York city.
So I have 50 year learnIng how to box.
Yeah.
And I'd always had a pretty intense
relationship with my body as an athlete.
Right.
So I wasn't starting from zero.
I've always been in really good shape.
Um,
and,
but I had never boxed before and I'd
never done anything like that.
And what I loved about mendez,
it's an old gym in New York and it's
like leeson's.
It's in manhattan.
And uh,
what I loved about it is that there were
some very tough kids from the outer
boroughs,
right?
There was like suits that would come in
from wall street at lunchtime to box.
There was women,
there was all kinds of people,
wealthy people,
poor people,
black,
white,
whatever it was.
Every everyone's in there,
right?
What I loved about it is that no one,
no one brought their street identity
into the,
into the gym,
right?
You were,
it's just like a platoon in combat.
You weren't,
you were judged in there not for whether
you're young and black and poor or
wealthy and affluent and white,
whatever,
but how you act in the gym.
And there was no prejudice that I can
see against the young black kids that
are in there.
But there's also no prejudice against
the wealthy white guys break.
As long as you leave it at that street,
you,
whoever you are in that space and you
get all the respect you want,
if you act well and that is the deep
egalitarian ism of a tribal society,
you're judged by how you act and that's
it.
That's the same thing.
Which schools you're judged by your
effort and how well you can perform on
the mats.
Right?
And don't listen.
I'm a middle aged.
I'm a middle aged guy,
right?
I mean,
I'm never going to win a championship.
I mean I've never.
I mean,
what am I going to do professionally
with boxing?
It's not happening,
but I woke up really,
really hard.
I'm not afraid to get hit like,
and I have all the.
I mean everyone in the gym knows me and
I have all the respect I could ever
want.
And through that struggle also you
achieved some feeling of peace because
you're strong.
I mean,
it's a brutal struggle.
Boxing for people who've never tried it.
It's unbelievably exhausting.
I,
I mean I thought for 12 mile was the
hardest thing I could imagine.
I had no idea what a one hour session,
like a really intense one hour training
session was like much less sparring,
much left getting hit in the liver.
Yeah.
I just,
I mean annihilating and,
and um,
but I was in a lot of psychic pain and I
needed.
Yeah,
I really feel like I'm especially
physical struggle.
I mean there's a lot of people that are
averse to exercise and like,
I can't stress it enough.
I think the body needs physical
struggle.
I think if you don't,
I think there's an overflow of energy
and stress that's unmanaged and it
manifests itself in a very physical way.
There was a,
there was a study that I read of,
um,
I mean there were a few hundred gatherer
societies that are still in existence
and the average amount of physical
activity in subsistence level,
hunter gatherer societies,
which of course is our evolutionary
past.
I mean that's what we are designed to
do,
um,
is something like two hours of hard
walking per day on average men and women
moved like vigorously for two hours a
day,
usually walking quickly.
Right?
That's what our bodies are designed for
and it's what if we do that,
we're that we're tuned up at that level,
right?
We're where our mind feels good,
our bodies feel good,
and if you don't do that,
I mean you can lay around all day,
but it will not.
You will,
you will experience a death,
a psychological deficit and a physical
deficit.
Yeah,
I think that,
I mean there's no way to make people do
it,
but I think if you could give people
advice that would be one of the big
ones.
And you know,
in western society,
the older you get,
the more money you tend to have more
sedentary,
you are.
And there's a corresponding decline in
testosterone levels in males.
Right?
What they found in these very mobile
physical societies is that testosterone
levels in males really didn't decline
until the seventies,
seventies,
the seventies.
I mean,
decline slowly,
but it didn't go off a cliff like it
does in our society at five or whatever
it is.
Like it was a gradual decline and if
there was a cliff,
it was in the mid seventies.
And that's because,
I mean,
the theory was that it was because that
constant intense physical activity
testosterone allows for it,
but that activity actually keeps those
levels high and it's a symbiotic
relationship.
No,
it completely makes sense for one of the
things that they prescribed a middle
aged man is sprints,
you know,
run up hills like a carry heavy things.
Do squats,
do things that stimulate your entire
body.
We're boxing or boxing.
Yeah.
All those things.
Listen,
man,
uh,
I've taken up enough of your time and I
really appreciate it and I'm really
enjoying your book and I'm looking
forward to a documentary and it's hell
on earth and it's available this sunday.
What time does it say up there?
What time?
It is?
11.
Oh,
an nice june.
11th,
nine eastern,
eight central.
And uh,
I've,
I've enjoyed your work over the years,
man.
So it was a real pleasure to sit down
and talk to you.
I really enjoyed this conversation.
Was really,
really nice.
Great conversation.
All right man.
Thank you very much.
My pleasure.
That's it folks.
See you.